hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the first
chapter of Zarathustra discourses in the
first part of the spoke zarathustra
Nietzsche begins by having Zarathustra
set out for us three metamorphoses
Siobhan Logan transformations from one
state into another and this is a rather
enigmatic set of passages if we consider
it solely in terms of the images alone
but if we if we look at the explanations
that Zarathustra is providing it makes
entire sense why you would need to move
first to one then to the next and then
to the next and Nietzsche is not setting
out some sort of developmental theory
here that says that everybody goes
through these or this is the only way to
proceed but he's setting out a path that
a person could in fact follow and we
have the transformation of the spirit
first into a camel and then from the
camel into a lion and then from the lion
into a child and you might say well you
know camel and lion that makes perfect
sense
they're both creatures they have their
own natures they can you know live in
the desert that he's talking about a
child
I don't know about that but what is a
child a child is a not yet finished and
formed human being potentiality as
Nietzsche is going to say a new start so
it actually does make good sense he's
not saying by the way that anybody or
everybody could or should follow this
path of the three metamorphoses but this
is what the person that he's writing the
book to the person who does in fact have
a spirit that is is capable of spirit or
mind a guise that is up to the tasks of
self transformation that's what they
could do and these really are genuine
transformations there is something good
that's being attained in each of the
states something that's necessary for
one's development but then it gets left
behind it gets it gets actually what's
good gets turned into the burden that
has to be abandoned or recognized as no
longer sufficient so he says I'm going
to name you these three metamorphoses
the spirit becomes a camel the camel
will lie on the line at last a child how
does the spirit become a camel he says
so there are many heavy things for the
spirit things that are difficult to bear
share in German right things that weigh
upon us and he's going to give it the
whole you know list of these that we'll
go through then he talks about the
strong stark weight bearing tog anda
that the one who could drag things
spirit in which dwells respect and awe
Erfurt right a respect for things that
are noble that are good that are perhaps
even holy a recognition of values so
this is not just anybody who can become
a camel it's the person who recognizes
something beyond merely the satisfaction
of their appetites or their vanity
something we could say greater than
themselves something that that requires
of them some sacrifices or
acknowledgement and then
says it's strength longs for the heavy
for the heaviest so again he's making a
distinction here it's not just the
people that can put up with stuff when
you really are strong you want to find
occasions to use if not necessarily
demonstrate to others that strength that
you have you want to do it for yourself
if you know that you can you know run a
long ways well then you want to run a
long ways so that you can show yourself
that you're still capable of it now
let's look at some of the examples that
he provides he says well what is the
heaviest thing right
what is heavy says the weight bearing
spirit it kneels down like the camel and
wants to be well laden what is the
heaviest thing you heroes that I can
take it upon me and rejoice in my
strength is it not this to debase
yourself in order to injure your pride
you already feel proud of yourself is it
not to take on even more that shows that
you're not so great to humble yourself
says to let your follies shine out in
order to mock your wisdom or is it this
to desert our cause when it is
celebrating its victory or to climb high
mountains in order to tempt the tempter
or to feed on the acorns and grass of
knowledge and for the sake of truth to
suffer hunger of the soul acknowledging
something greater than oneself right not
needing to be the center of attention
not mating not needing to make it all
about oneself although it is kind of all
about oneself in a different way isn't
it then he says or is it this to be sick
and send away comforters and make
friends with the Deaf who never hear
what you asked to suffer without
expecting other people to succour you
right or is it this to wade into dirty
water which is the water of truth and
not to disdain cold frogs and hot toads
or is it this to love those who despise
us and offer our hand to the ghost when
it wants to frighten us so he goes on
and says whatever burden you're taking
on the weight bearing spirit takes on
these head
things like a camel hurrying laden into
the desert
thus it hurries into the desert now
before we go on to the lion how is this
day a transformation well you could take
on these burdens and then complain about
or you know write a little tweet about
it Oh such a hard day do some vague
booking on Facebook right oh it's so
rough for me
right people do that sort of thing all
the time they're not a camel they're
just a complainer the camel is saying
this is actually going to be good for me
I am going to take this stuff on I don't
know if I'm really up to it but let's
see and holy crap I am enduring it I'm
making it
let me bear this burden and go out into
the desert and that's where the second
transformation happens the
transformation from the camel into a new
state of being the lion in the text
right the lion is what we talk about the
the king of the jungle but really you
know deserts were really scary place to
run into a lion because they're giant
their fearsome and there's nowhere to
hide in the desert is there so the lion
is also sort of so to speak the king of
the desert and if you look at ancient
art you see people hunting lions trying
to drive them out of these these
wastelands right so he says in the
loneliest desert the second
metamorphosis occurs the spirit becomes
a lion what is this about what does this
symbolize it wants to take on freedom so
before it was about taking on burdens
now those burdens are gone it wants to
take on freedom freedom for what freedom
to run around and you know find an oasis
and drink some water eat some gazelles
know the freedom to rule itself to be
Lord in its own desert and here
Nietzsche says you run into something
that would otherwise beat you down and
that the camel could acknowledge as
right and the lion is going to say
I will not put up with this so it says
it seeks here its ultimate Lord its lets
them right in each of these cases its
ultimate Lord it will be an enemy to him
and to its ultimate God
it will struggle for victory with the
Great Dragon so we have three things
here all of which are ruling were
presenting themselves as dangerous Lord
ruler God creator of everything perhaps
dragon this figure of the dragon what
does it mean
he says the great dragon is called Val
shell the spirit of the lion
in contrast says to it I will and we're
going to come back to that in a moment
so he says thou shalt lies on its path
sparkling with gold the scale covered
beast on every scale glitters golden bow
shelf so it's not just one single thou
shalt or imperative or rule or you know
social Moray or something like that
instead it's it's a thousand of them
it's an entire system
you're being confronted by this great
beast every single scale of which is a
rule for you a procedure an order a way
that you ought to be and the lion says
screw you I'm gonna do my own thing I am
going to be free of you and in doing so
the lion doesn't confront the the dragon
with a I've got a bigger thou shalt than
your thou shalt soar anything like that
he doesn't play that game and stead he
opposes to that I will I'm going to do
this I choose for myself I'll create
this space of freedom and forget about
your rules I'll fight against you so he
says values of a thousand years glitter
around the scales and thus speaks the
mightiest of dragons all the values of
things glitter on me the system opposes
you and says I am the embodiment of
goodness of rightness of beauty of value
of whatever it happens to be I've got
the answers you need to get in line with
the prescriptions that I have for you
you
you need to obey these rules you need to
acknowledge these values even if you
don't live up to them you should at
least feel guilty about not living up to
them you should at least acknowledge
that you're a failure and the lion says
screw you I'm in charge here I'm not in
charge of you
I'm not in charge of all the people who
buy into you but I'm in charge of myself
and my little plot of this desert which
maybe is just where my paws are but
that's mine and I'm not going to listen
to you or allow you to push me around so
the dragon says another thing all values
have already been created all created
values are in me truly there shall be no
more
I will thus speaks the dragon there is
nothing new Under the Sun I've already
got you figured out you rebellious
little you know snot lion and the lion
can say well maybe you think you do
but I'm gonna oppose you I will I'm
gonna oppose my will to your dollar
shelf I don't buy your story and I don't
even have to disprove you all I have to
do is stand up to you and I'm already
doing it
so Nietzsche goes on he says to create
freedom for itself in a sacred no even
to duty the lion is needed for that my
brothers we have to turn ourselves into
lions so that we can say a sacred no now
this is not yet something positive this
is not yet a way forward but it's it's
needed to clear the space in which
freedom can be exercised without that
exercise of freedom we cannot in effect
go further so we first have the camel
camel we carry all the things out of the
desert then we have the lion we shed
those burdens we confront the dragon
that seems to have all the answers we
say forget you I'm free the lion is not
the the final point though you can't
live just in rebellion or revolt or a
revolution or whatever you're going to
be right so he says to create freedom
for that right we need the Lions to
seize the right to new value
that is the most terrible proceeding for
a weight bearing and reverential spirit
truly to the spirited as the theft and
work for an animal of prey once as the
camel it loved that thou shalt as its
holy holiest thing now it has to find
illusion and Caprice even in the holiest
that it makes steal freedom from its
love the lion is needed for this theft
but nature goes on what can the child do
that the lion cannot why must the
praying lion still become a child why
does it have to you know the lion is
something really quite magnificent and
powerful why does it have to become this
weak pale flabby vulnerable thing that
is the child because the child can do
something that the lion cannot where the
lion can only say no the child can say
yes where the lion can create the space
for creation the child can actually
create and that's why we cannot just
stop with the lion any more than we can
stop just with the camel according to
Nietzsche if we want to fully develop so
he tells us the child is innocence and
forgetfulness a new beginning perhaps
dropping grudges you know no longer
insisting on that that damn dragon and
all the work that he imposed on me and
you know how he scared me up no the
child is something new a potentiality
that otherwise we would miss out on if
we stay stuck in the lion he calls him a
sport a self propelling wheel the first
motion a sacred yes and the Nietzsche
says the sacred yes is needed for the
sport of creation what does that mean he
tells us two key components to this
wheeling its own will being creative in
valuation creating new values creating
new i wills being open to the world in a
way that the lion who's needed in order
to fight against this this dragon in
order to keep the thou shalt away in a
way that the lion cannot
so willing one's own will becomes truly
possible only as the child
Nietzsche goes further and says
something very interesting because
willing one's own will okay that's
really great but he says by doing that
it winds its own world it's no longer
just closed up in itself in negation of
something it winds not the entire world
but its own world its own space where it
doesn't have to be taking on all the
burdens saying all the knows in which
something more is possible to have a
world is to have relations to things
that are other than yourself
and for those to be positive creative
with value generating relations that is
what Nietzsche is is telling us about
here so he says I have named you these
three metamorphoses in the spirit how
the spirit became a camel the camel a
lion the lion at least at last a child
these are steps that Nietzsche thinks
are necessary for us to liberate
ourselves and truly become creative and
truly set our own destiny and path
within a world that we choose
you